Speaker 1: Let's speak to a couple of
other people. Why not write? I mean,
we're doing it. We might as well. Let's
talk to how about Tom from Boston,
Tom from Boston. You're on the air.
Speaker 4: How's it going, David? Going well.
So a couple of weeks ago, you were talking
about needing like a mass deprogramming for
the conspiratorial thinkers and the hard core
trumpeter's. Yeah. And then last week, you
mentioned that you were reading Going Clear, and
it got me thinking that I really don't think that
a mass deprogramming is very likely. I agree with
you. I think I think we're much more likely to
see a Scientology type situation where it's just
slowly chipped away at. I think that it's possible
that if more of Trump's records come out during
this whole, you know, case with his company,
that could do some damage. But I really think
you're just going to see all of these groups
that kind of came together to support
him splintered off. And yeah, I mean,
Speaker 1: the thing about that is
Scientology, 74 million people voted for Trump.
Scientology at its peak was a fraction
of a fraction of a fraction of that.
So we could be talking about it. If we're just
doing if we're doing that, we have to we might
have to work to wait two thousand years. Right.
Speaker 4: So I guess that is true,
that there are a lot of a lot
of comparisons you can draw.
There are pretty legendary con men.
Speaker 1: It's actually crazy in
reading. So what Tom is talking about is that
I mentioned and reading Lawrence Wright's
sort of profile of the history of Scientology and
L. Ron Hubbard called going clear. And in reading
it, the way people kind of got sucked in is very
Trumpy in L. Ron Hubbard himself is very Trumpy.
And it's super interesting to read because it's
so analogous to Trump Trump ism. Yeah, I mean,
I think I think you're right. Masti programing is
difficult. One of the most efficient ways to mass
the program is with a completely authoritarian
takeover. Right. But that's bad. That's a bad
way to because you're all you're really doing is
Speaker 4: you're repointing Miscavige. Exactly
right.
Speaker 1: You're
just reprograming into something else in an
equally authoritarian way. So it's tough. Yeah.
As I've said, I don't really have a solution,
but your solution likely is sensible. It'll
just take a really, really, really long time.
Speaker 4: Unfortunately, I don't think we're
I don't think it's going to be a quick thing.
No, no. By no means. All right, well, thanks.
And if you haven't read Lawrence Wright's The
Looming Tower, definitely give that a read. Oh,
what's that one? That's his his history
of al-Qaida and the lead up to 9/11.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK. I'll check
that out. I recently read
Speaker 4: it's a Pulitzer winner.
Speaker 1: He wrote a novel,
a pandemic novel called The End of October. And I
recently wrote that as well. Yeah, it's really you
Speaker 4: have to check that
out. Yeah, he's quite good.
Speaker 1: He's very good. Very
good. All right, Tom, thank you.
Speaker 4: All right. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Very good calls about
books. I mean, guys, what more can you ask
for? Right. It's just an incredible day here